the great comics will make you feel dumb
in such a similar way i remember a tale
once i was wearing like a big soft
sweater and a tell just walked up to me
and touched and goes hmm
it just crushed me i was like oh god who
do i think i am taking a fashion risk at
the seller
not even a joke not a punch line the
punchline is a noise
ah it's brilliant it just made me feel
so stupid for taking a chance yeah with
a different outfit there's that famous
story i've told it a million times where
joe derosa bought his first leather
jacket he showed up the cellar and
somebody goes oh joe's got his attitude
jacket
and that just brings you right back down
to earth
i love it and we need that because you
see people on twitter online going off
about this and you're like oh nobody's
put you in check in a while it's
actually they're helping you it's the
future
when you don't have that help is when
you go out and you really are a
tone-deaf comedian right so they're
almost being like i'm gonna keep you
semi-hating yourself yeah i'm not i
don't want you to hate-hate yourself i
just want you to have like a healthy
amount of self-loathing they're kind of
helping you is the funny thing totally
totally yeah that's why on the seller
for good or for bad you're always kind
of on edge you can't really soak it up
you can't really let luge camper it's
different now it's different now but
back in the day but i was in a i was in
the vu last night it was me bobby kelly
liz and somebody else and i said
something they all went off on me i was
like oh yeah i'm with the right people
here it's the best it's good i mean
bobby who would be great on this we
gotta get him oh geez bobby liz i mean
there's so many great
people who just make you feel like a
dummy and that and that is love in a
weird it is it's love totally yeah it's
like when they say you only roast the
ones you love and then you see like a
lot of those roasts are just casted with
strangers but these are people who
actually know you and are [ __ ] on
you
and coming up with a joke to burn
someone is work yeah so they're working
to show you affection essentially yeah
good point good point and
they know what you're going through like
when you have this [ __ ] bravado
moment or you know your fluffy sweater
they know you feel weird about it so
when you when they zing you
it's almost like yeah you're right
because i would have done that to you
and it's it's almost the the love is
telling you the truth yeah that's really
what it comes down to the going i love
your sweater oh my god it's great you're
so cute oh look at you that feels good
for 10 seconds but you're like it's like
telling a girlfriend like no you haven't
gained weight the love is telling her
that she has you're you're huge you need
a rascal you big big [ __ ] come on
all right we'll keep you should we do
emails yeah we got some emails